this is something i've always wanted to
ask you about and i've been excited to
ask you about it since i've gotten to
know you a bit and now's maybe a good
time
um because i i heard you on a podcast a
while back when when you were first
um campaigning for president and and you
were talking about
universal basic income but then you were
also saying
like and you you could don't
put words in your mouth you could
express this better than i could but you
were talking about like
having other programs and structures to
support
kind of productivity and
like community driven collaborative
efforts whether it's in art or in other
fields that we're not necessarily driven
by
a commercial market but um but we're
driven by
other modes of oh yeah yeah i'm so
interested in
how that works because i don't know that
commerce is the only way to drive
art yeah thank you for calling that out
uh so to me pillar number one is like
put money into people's hands
would folks have more freedom to create
yes would they have more ability to
reward artists and creators yes if you
had better structures in place
but there's like this whole set of
activities that
has been eroding for years and decades
the united states of america
that we i think most of us agree are
like pretty positive stuff that the
market
just is not going to love and one thing
that
like you know i use as an example when i
travel is like local papers local
newspapers
local newspapers are getting wiped out
like you know a thousand local paper is
gone
and democracy does not function as well
if you don't have local papers
uh so let's let's say even if we had
more money in a community
sure some more local papers would
survive but maybe you decide that
local journalism is good regardless of
whether or not like the advertising
makes
money or you know like the the
subscriptions and so
if you start looking at some things that
maybe we can agree are positive which i
would definitely put art in this
category i'd put local journalism in
this category
i put volunteering for a civic
organization
um in this category and so volunteerism
is down
uh like pretty much anything where like
that there's something that you
regard as positive in the community um
has been declining by the numbers
for years and so there's like this whole
suite of activities
where i don't think any of us
necessarily wants to get quote unquote
paid for everything
it's like hey if i you know volunteer
for the non-profit like non-profit pay
me
it's like like there has to be like some
sort of activity you do that's like
non-monetary but also um something that
we
we want to reward or reinforce and so my
idea was essentially you create like a
parallel
economy around this other set of
activities
that could that we could use another
currency for or time
and it was based on something called
time banking where um
in the 60s rfk's speechwriter was trying
to figure out how to help
poor communities become more socially
connected
and what they came up with was something
called time banking where if i
babysit your kids then you get me back
by hauling like logs off my lawn
and we essentially just trade like units
of time with each other
um and so you could introduce like a
different currency or
time units into this other set of
activities
that we know we need more of but you
don't want to pay people for because
it's like a little messed up
so and and i would certainly put art in
this category where if someone produces
public art
uh then they would get uh you know this
other
currency reward or other people get them
back in various ways
it'd be a way to try and stitch together
uh social interactions
and and and also you could disclose it
publicly in a way that you don't money
so if i'm like hey i made a thousand
bucks like i'm an [ __ ] if i'm like
waving around like my thousand dollars
my head but it but if i got these like
you know um a thousand
um social points or whatever you call
them
um then you could actually broadcast it
in a way that everyone finds perfectly
socially acceptable
um and then you could even give those
social points to someone else
um and uh and then they could use it for
various things so that was like
the thinking around like uh that like
you you need something
non-monetary for certain activities
that you want to help see more of can i
ask you more about how that will work i
know you haven't like
fleshed it out entirely so this is maybe
just a totally hypothetical situation
but i just find that
so fascinating i want to ask you more
about like so
in in the case of an artist say because
that's obviously what's close to my
heart and experience
so someone who who
makes some art say they make a a song
they record a song
and it's it's not necessarily like the
kind of commercially viable song
that a record label is going to invest
in or something
but they they have the potential to earn
this sort of whether it's like time time
banking or social points or
whatever you call it how there there
would have to be what some kind of
system in place that would determine
whether how many social points that song
is
worth or like how would that kind of so
my thinking on this and this is actually
very close to the conversation i was
having with the musicians online
um would be that if i listen to the song
just by virtue of my listening to the
song you get like a social credit
uh for the fact that i listen to it it's
like essentially a micropayment thing
okay so everybody who listens to it then
that
right okay so it does have to do with um
the audience that you garner for the art
that you create
yeah right but so because right now
the way that you can make money
uh or get any kind of compensation for
that sort of thing is say you put your
song
on youtube or your video on youtube or
whatever
and youtube is able to if if
a million or more people come and watch
your videos and youtube
might make enough money on ads that
they'll give you like a few bucks
um well this is this is the distinction
you drew initially
um joseph because i've been struggling
with how the heck we got we would get
this done on a
you know societal level you essentially
want the world to look more like netflix
than youtube
right right it's like where we're paying
but in this case
you don't necessarily want and i think
like
tier one which would be better is if we
all had money and we're all paying
for stuff but then tier two would be
like hey i'm paying with my attention
and you can take like this attention
currency and
use that for various things too some of
which could be monetary um
because you want to try and get the like
because right right now people are
conditioned to consume art and content
for free or near free
um and then you pay you then you pay a
subscription and then you're like okay
now i'm in the walled garden and i get
like the cool
like movie or tv show from like the the
joseph
levitz of the world and so what you want
to do is you want to create like
like closer to that walled garden
dynamic um out there
like uh where if you pay attention to
something then the creator is getting
rewarded
um and it doesn't necessitate my
whipping out my credit card
right right because someone has spent
their time
on your art so if it were time banking
it would be that
that kind of thing yeah yes and so like
that the time actually has value
um right and then and then if people
have elected to spend their time on your
art
then you actually like build up this
time currency
that you you know you could trade for
dollars like you know there could be
like an exchange rate essentially
right so and in order for that to happen
it would just it would have to be
kind of top down right like the
government would have to say okay there
is
the government is just like the
government does with dollars like
dollars is a top-down thing the
government
says we the united states government are
deciding that u.s dollars are
valuable right and and so you're saying
that like
the the government would have to say
we're also saying now that
time is valuable and here is a like
government-built structure like
institution for
how we can exchange
time currency so here's where it gets
interesting
that time banking is an effect right now
in hundreds of communities around the
country
like that they're just doing it
informally they have some ledger they'll
keep keep track of it
um and there are also some apps
uh like there's one called seven
exchange they have karma points
there are different things where they're
starting to try and monitor this so
if you were a foundation or philanthropy
or a billionaire or whatnot
i know some of these characters so this
isn't entirely hypothetically
like could you go in and say hey guys
guess what like we're we're going to
essentially guarantee your time currency
at like a certain exchange
um and uh so if you do something for
someone you develop
you know you get get a credit or you
produce public art and people want to
reward it
um and then if you want like we've got
like essentially like an exchange bank
and i'm going to monetize it to the tune
of
a million bucks 10 million bucks
whatever it is uh and
and the fun thing about this is that you
could potentially create
like like a hundred million worth
of uh interactions or social activity
with like a much smaller level of money
um but you would need to essentially do
it within a community the same way that
communities are doing it with time
banking right now
i agree with you in a macro level you'd
probably need the government uh
lending a hand like if you wanted to do
it like throughout the entire us economy
and you were dealing with like massive
um numbers but you could pilot this in a
community
um certainly in terms of in-person
activities
and it's happening now and then the
trickier thing which is something that i
genuinely think that we need to be
investing a ton of energy
and resources on is how to make it
happen in the digital
universe is how to make it so that like
your time is actually
uh monetizable in a different way than
advertising because
we have to face facts that right now so
much of our internet
enjoyment or whatever is based on
advertising and there was a period when
it seemed like okay this is cool like
i've got
you know free facebook free youtube free
this um but now it's degenerated into
this form of
pernicious surveillance capitalism
[Laughter]
where they're like and among other
problems it's absolute [ __ ] for creators
yes yeah i think it really is
and uh and it's not
just um it's not just the ads it's
what comes with the ads
like you mentioned the difference
between like a netflix and a youtube and
again i'm saying again
there's lots of great stuff on youtube i
love youtube i
i look at youtube all the time and i
find amazing things i never would have
been able to find anywhere else like
youtube's incredible but there there is
a difference between
um what youtube will recommend versus
what
netflix will recommend because there's a
difference between how they're
monetizing
the viewers that uh netflix is
trying to serve viewers something that's
so good and meaningful to them that
they're willing to pay out of their
pocket for it whereas youtube is trying
to serve up things
that are just gonna like catch your
attention and keep your attention
and it doesn't have to be it doesn't
have to be
so profound or meaningful that you would
pay money for it that doesn't
it doesn't have to be that it just has
to kind of catch you enough
to keep your attention and those are two
different
offerings that are that are a result of
those two different
models and it i i like as an artist
i i'm much more interested in making art
not that's just gonna catch someone's
attention and kind of like
hook them and keep their attention i'm
interested in making stuff that's
going to be really meaningful to
somebody that they're going to think
about afterwards it's going to like
they're going to remember
you create different work based upon one
goal and the other
the other thing is that if you do
succeed in catching someone's attention
even for like x minutes and then
afterwards you're like okay like what
did i
uh get like as the creator i mean right
now
you know in many cases it's uh next to
nothing or nothing um
and and then that doesn't create like an
ecosystem that enables that artist to
like
do something else reinvest you know like
pay themselves
have health care like you know what
whatever like the
um like whatever the basics that we'd
expect anyone who's working
um you know creatively to have thank you
for listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you